welcome to the hunter exam first phase
run 80 kilometres through a dark tunnel
first phase and a half run through a
deceptive swamp alongside a creepy
magician second phase cooking third
phase tricky tower maze game thing
fourth phase subscribe to the new world
review for regular hunt under content
upload it straight into your YouTube
feed fifth phase shown in battle
tournament good luck with your exam
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we are going to
begin a journey through the story of
hunter hunter whereby I will be
reviewing all nine arcs one by one
starting here today with the hunter exam
but before I do hop into what I do want
to note that these are not going to be
arc breakdowns or recaps I mean I might
do something like that in the future as
well but this is going to be a strict
review ie my personal impressions of an
arc including what worked for me what
didn't and the overall impact they had
on the series from my perspective and
with that out of the way I would like to
welcome you to the very first edition of
the hunter hunter arc review the hunter
exam is the inaugural walk within the
series consisting of 38 manga chapters
21 episodes of the 1999 anime adaptation
and also 21 episodes of the 2011
adaptation the general premise
introduces us to our four major
protagonists in the series in gone Kilwa
tropica and lee oreo as they each embark
on a series of tests to attain a hunter
license which coincidentally is the
first step towards all the thick rater
goals
well bar killer actually and this
section of the story really does show
hunter hunter at its most innocent and
adventurous the hunter exam presents a
series and quite possibly its most basic
shown in incarnation because as we know
Hunter hunter evolves quite rapidly
between arcs becoming almost entirely
unrecognizable in its later stages but
that said the hunter exam arc is
actually quite a good microcosm
representation of the series as a whole
because even at its most basic it is a
showing of togarashi not quite knowing
where he wanted to hunt on to be as a
series because essentially the hunter
exam is composed of a string of tests
with each one radically redefining what
kind of story he was telling at any
given moment in time now these periods
only last a handful of chapters before
moving on
unlike entire future arcs of the series
but I do find it interesting how we can
delve into a stage entirely focused on
cooking and cuisine very much of okie a
food wall style feeling even though
Hunter hunter predates that
significantly however we
then instantly be thrown into a stage
full of psychological games with
restrictive and creative mechanics in
trick tower which is nothing more along
the lines of what a series like laia
game would deliver once again in Toronto
predates it and they're moving into the
fourth stage things take a very Hunger
Game style of turn and in the final
stage we have ourselves a standard
Chernin battle tournament although with
a very non-standard twist so the hunter
exam despite feeling quite simple in
many ways shows us from a very early
stage that Takashi is not afraid to shun
remix in this series and that he will
essentially just draw whatever he feels
particularly passionate about at that
point in time which I love and I think
that it's gone on shape hunter hunter
has a completely unique product in the
shona marketplace but that said there
are certainly many aspects of the hunter
exam that falls squarely into the trophy
category with one being the pure but
absent minded main protagonist that is
gone gone in this arc and I want to make
it clear that I'm very much talking
exclusively about the hunter exam gives
me everything I was expecting of him
every step of the way
he doesn't surprise me at all because I
understand his archetype character he's
a simple lad who grew up in nature and
doesn't like to over complicate matters
which often leads him to enacting
effective solutions that more complex
Minds are incapable as thinking of
probably one of the greatest examples of
this is in the trick towel phase where
gun is challenged to a contest see whose
candle would burn out first and he just
simply blows out his opponents candle to
win easy and effective and that's not to
say that any of this is a detriment I
think that gon works very well during
the hunter exam arc and his simplicity
is a good constant amongst an
ever-changing environment and even
overall story genre looking back on it
though I'm pretty astounded at just how
gone changes throughout the series
because he just feels so young and
vibrant during the hunter exam arc which
is a nice shot of energy at times
because they audio crop occur and
kilowatt do not give you that they're
all awesome in their own ways but each
held back by implementing basic logic
which come on is never any fun what I
really do enjoy seeing though is a much
more laid-back kora pika which we get a
surprising amount of I mean he does get
serious on a couple of occasions like
when he encountered the fake phantom
troop member and he's mostly a delight
to be around during this initial lock
and another surprise to look back on is
Kilowog because it's very difficult to
compare his modern incarnation with his
initial chapters especially when he so
willingly presents a variety of
antagonistic features such as when he
killed his two fellow examinees for well
no real good reason he was just slightly
annoyed and when I was first going
through hunter
this is one of those moments that made
me think the kill off would eventually
become an antagonist in the series
because he had this very well I guess
I'll describe it as a Hisoka vibe about
him the kilowatt is here to serve as one
of the most important figures of the
hunter exam art which is to convey very
early on in series just how profoundly
brutal this world is it's something that
you can forget from time to time for the
currently pure of heart gone and tis
helpful friends around but this arc is a
complete slaughter fest hundreds of
people died during this particular part
of the story and did this one of the
most part thirsty arcs within the entire
series with some particularly brutal
depictions that in some cases I'm
shocked were given the greenlight to be
published in a shounen manga I mean for
example he soaked it decapitates at
least two people during the hunter exam
one of which being the guy in trick
tower and the other being Greta
in the fourth phase after he coke on
earth god this world is unforgiving and
I'm so glad that that was established
from the get-go because to this day I
can never be sure who will meet an
untimely demise in hunter hunter no
matter how established they are as a
character and I think that the hunter
exam can be credited quite strongly for
setting up the stone I mean some of the
characters you know are destined to die
because Takashi didn't put a whole lot
of effort into their designs then you
also have individuals like the
aforementioned Greta who has had quite a
bit of effort put into his aesthetic
creation so as much as you would think
that he'd be a guaranteed pass or at
least a finalist and perhaps even
relevant in the future no Takashi shows
with him as well as many other
characters that he is happy to discard
these figures at a moment's notice for
the sake of the story I love that but
going back to Hisoka for a bit this guy
is undoubtedly my highlight of the
hunter exam he was an absolutely
necessary presence and was able to
provide that really sinister laya and I
think this awkward have been sorely
missing without him because there are
plenty of killers in the Sauk and people
who commit uncouth actions but none of
them do so with the kind of demonic aura
that Hisoka exudes every time he appears
in a panel in the manga or on screen in
the anime it was a big oh [ __ ] moment
because out of all the examinees this
was the one guy that we really did not
want to be around his very presence
conjured a feeling of danger within me
as a reader and a viewer and that is a
very difficult thing for any creator to
be able to pull off so full credit to
togarashi
for nailing Hisoka from the get-go the
extended cast for a lot of fun though
and there's something very charming
about taking a large group of characters
and having them face multiple trials
together and even be pit against each
other I would say that Hanzo is another
stand out of the ark for me it was a
masterful mixture of comedy and power as
well as some genuine drama when he and
Gaughan faced off against each other
in the final stage of the exam and
speaking of the final stage there is a
potential negative in the storytelling
of the hunter exam ah in that it ends on
a distinct anticlimax a lot of which was
going to be inevitable due to how
naturally set up the final stage
tournament bracket but the first time I
remember going through the series I do
favorite lyric all going is that it
simply because it wasn't what I had come
to expect from assurance series however
in retrospect I think that's one of the
greatest strengths of the hunter exam ah
it ends suddenly and without any massive
action required but at the same time it
also flows seamlessly into the next arc
being resulted family plus there's also
the revelation that the exam isn't over
just yet so it kind of makes sense to
not have that feeling of finality to it
but that said I can understand if many
people including myself initially wanted
a more satisfying cap to the arc but at
the same time I think this also
adequately prepares us for the rest of
Hunter hunter because in this series
sometimes things are just going to end
and not in the way that you may expect
and as a result I think that hunter
hunter has it's very organic almost
realistic atmosphere about it which is
absurd to say about a magic wielding
world but this atmosphere is crafted
entirely through narrative because more
often than not real life does not result
in climaxes that we see in everyday film
or television which might sound quite
disappointing but that's also what makes
life so unpredictable and so captivating
and the fact that hunter hunter could
replicate that not early in the series
of odd but in its very first dark sets
it apart from many if not all of its
contemporaries as a whole though I think
the hunter exam works narratively
because it plays upon an easy hook and I
say this because I for one I'm always
taken in by the concept of a deadly game
I love it when you throw characters into
a situation with defined rules and very
real consequences which is what this
entire rock is constantly throwing at us
I also think it's a lot easier to
compose from a storytelling perspective
than more freeform great world stuff
where there are no rules
and so characters need an even deeper
motivation for each one of their actions
but Takashi would come to prove to be a
master of that as well and really the
hunter exam was pretty much just a test
run for him a little bit of time in the
sandbox to play around with this world
and these characters extracting their
potential and then moving forward to
catapult them into a greater world
context and so as much as the hunter
exam could never be cold my favorite arc
probably not even close actually I do
have
a lot to be thankful to it for it's not
a bad arc by any means and I still find
it quite enjoyable to go through but it
just doesn't have the depth of world or
characters that hunter hunter would
eventually evolve into however it did
lay a lot of that groundwork and I
recognize it as a very necessary and
enjoyable step in the life of the series
and that pretty much does it for this
review of the hunter exam on if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produce in general then please
do consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your star
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
for this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
Shannara takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on the hunter exam on this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
do you review Hunter Hunter series from
1999 not currently no mostly because I'm
not qualified because I haven't actually
seen all of it for some context I became
indoctrinated into the world of Hunter
hunter through the 2011 anime then I
went on to experience the series again
through the manga I have seen a fair few
of the episodes of the 1999 anime
adaptation and for posterity's sake I
should really go back and watch at all
but I haven't quite found the time as of
yet although I think the most
interesting thing that could come out of
it would be being able to directly
compare the three stories which could
make for a fun series of videos I know
there are some pretty radical changes
between three incarnations which is why
we're making these videos I prefer to
just stick to the manga the simplicity
sake but if you've seen the entire 1999
run including all the Green Island OVA s
then please do let me know in the
comments below if it's worth the time
investment and if you haven't seen it
please do let me know if you'd like me
to watch it and make a bunch of videos
pointing out where changes are and such
from the original story